Senator Ted Cruz president Trump's Chief
rival in 2016 the man who almost beat
Trump for the nomination just came out
and endorsed him and and at this point I
I believe this race is over so so I am
proud to endorse Donald Trump for
president of the United States I look
forward to supporting him
enthusiastically because I think it's
time for the Republican party to unite
for us to come together we've got to
beat Joe Biden we've got to beat this
disastrous cultural Marxist agenda in
the White House we've got to retake the
United States Senate we've got to hold
the house we got to come together and
win and with the results last night the
people have spoken it's time to move
onward to victory in November I think
Senator Cruz handled this very well the
guy ran a brutal campaign against Trump
in 2016 then when Trump won Cruz got on
board they accomplished some great
things together they worked very well
together when Trump was president